having met some of the Eve players you
may have noticed a trend the game tends
to attract smart passionate often
devious people managing these people is
hard sort of like herding deranged cats
that have been doing lots of drugs for
13 years this management burden has been
the job of CCP games the Icelandic game
studio that invented Eve since Eve has
few rules CCP has had to work hand in
hand with the players to shape the game
and introduce new stuff to buy and new
places to go some of the key input from
both sides arrives at fan fest we're
important things like wormhole Terrans
we'll get debate are you concerned at
this point do you feel like it's about
the right balance the depth of this
two-way relationship is unique in the
gaming industry welcome to e5 phase 2016
one of the key people who shaped the
vision of EVE the CCP's longtime CEO
Hilmar patterson Hilmar is something of
a philosopher when it comes to iceland
science fiction and the role that Eve
may play in nothing less than the
evolution of the human species why does
it make so much sense that this game
started in Iceland when you're a kid in
Iceland you develop a clear sense that
the country is here to kill you
and if you don't pay attention you're
just gonna die where you have volcanoes
and blizzards and novel and seas and God
knows what you really have to band
together against the elements
you started out from humble beginnings
three young computer savvy ice lenders
raised the money to build Eve by selling
a board game called header shvil or the
danger game in English which ended up
being a smash hit funds in hand they
left from the dining room table to the
stars building a beautiful and iconic
interpretation of life in space as
Hilmar sees it Eve might now provide a
roadmap for an interstellar society we
very much think about the game as a
construct to inspire the manifest
destiny of mankind which is to grow
beyond this planet so we can I look at
him online the closest thing you have
today to live in space so and we believe
by giving hundreds of thousands and
millions of people that experience and
that dream we will bring closer to us
the that desire and drive to make it
actually concretely happen
CCP has just released a new game called
Valkyrie it's a pure blow em up high
action space war game built for the
virtual reality headsets just coming to
market investors have recently poured
money into CCP betting that it will
figure out how to merge the best parts
of EVE and Valkyrie and create the first
meaningful virtual social network where
do you see all this technology heading
what we wanted to do with Valkyrie was
to do something very more immersive
something like immediately impactful on
your kind of emotional state if does
that differently because it's more
slow-paced and methodical
there's more to your brain than to your
heart and ultimately the dream is to
kind of merge these two concepts
Gilmartin invitees but this guy did
he's Rainier Hardison one of the three
co-creators of the game he explained the
origins of EVE to me near a monument
located beside the Reykjavik marina it
was built to honor the Eve players with
their gamer handles itched into the base
all during fan fest people come to find
their names and pay homage to the game
people feel very passionate about this
and the strange thing about it when you
when you log into if it doesn't feel
like you're playing again it feels like
you're logging into real world and these
people feel it too and the reason is
because it's it's really about human you
know it's about humans interacting it's
about human emotion it's you know
whatever makes it human why do you think
we will get all that at their jobs and
then come and work another job and seek
to feel that at home after I would say
it's kind of you know it's in a strange
twisted way it's a it's a utopian
perfect mood
but it's riddled with warrants drivin
and everything but everyone can you know
aspire to be something big